the winner
[Music]
of american idol
chase beckham chase congratulations you
win
american idol congratulations my man
you deserve it you earned it you have
the ability
to back it up where where's your head at
right now how you feeling man
i don't know man i really just i want to
get together with my friends and family
and kind of just get the chance to
celebrate with them and
you know i did this for my family so
this is something that i really want to
enjoy with them
what was your very first thought
when they announced you as a winner i
mean whenever they
whenever i made top three and i was
there with willie and grace i was like
i'm out it was like this is the problem
so you know and then having to follow up
their performances as well tonight um
you know they're incredible man they're
just some of the best vocalists ever met
in my entire life so
uh to be standing up there next to
willie you know either way i was really
hoping that willie was gonna take it
home because you know he deserves it man
and um but i told him vice versa if i go
home
you know run her up or third we're just
equally as happy just this
has been such an awesome experience yeah
i mean i i agree with you it's a
remarkable
talent pool this year every year on idol
but this year seems to
even more so all you guys are so
talented i hope there's many records
in all your guys futures now you didn't
just win a record deal you won this cash
prize
what's the first thing you buy what's
the first thing you do now i'm fixing to
buy me a fishing boat
i can go fishing man that's it i got to
get out of
california and get out to nashville man
and
you know get get my my boots in the dirt
there and
kind of just settle in so yeah make a
big move
and uh go out there and keep chasing his
dream
what did what did katie luke and lionel
tell you afterwards right after it all
happened
i it's crazy because it's like all
season we don't really get to interact
with them too much and
finally got to give them all big hugs
and just give them all my love and just
you know
thanks to them my life has changed
completely so you know they just
gave me a lot of words of encouragement
me and luke are gonna go fishing when i
get to nashville
and uh yeah so it's
nothing but love from them you know i
love them they're honestly all three of
them is the best
you know after shows chase has been kind
of
teasing about wanting to uh do some bass
fishing one day so listen oh whoa i'm
i'm saying it right now me and you
you've you've earned your bass fishing
trick
now luke told you that that you earned
the bass fishing trip what do you make
of that whole beat
dude that's like i told luke when i made
it to top 24 i said
i don't care if i win i said if i make
it through into the top 24 i said you
got to take me fishing with bill dance
because i'm a big bill dance fan i love
bill dance and he said all right and so
i've been asking him and asked him i
said
when are you going to take me fishing
with bill dance and then finally tonight
i earned it so that's my real life goal
is to go fishing with bill dance so i'm
just checking stuff off my bucket list
man it's nice
oh man chase and singing with luke combs
singing with luke combs that was
bucket list dude right there so to get
to do that with him
on if luke if you're listening to this
thank you if you're reading this
thank you i love you huge inspiration to
[Music]
me
[Music]
man that's that's incredible you got to
sing with luke you win this competition
you're gonna go fishing it's all you
wanna do you did it for your family
could you be a better guy chase what's
your
what's your advice for the younger
singers performers
coming coming up trying to get their
career going trying to get on idol
what's your advice to them yeah i would
say if you're gonna do idle
you know just get as many songs as you
can together and
get about 50 or golly sorry about that
um people are saying um
i would say get all your songs together
and you have about 50 of them ready to
go
and uh and because whenever you get here
it's not
oh man i love this song and this is what
we're gonna sing you know you go through
and it's a process of elimination with
songs and stuff so it's
a lot of hard work but i guess if
anything you just come in here and
don't forget who you are you know come
come in and put yourself
out there and be ready for whatever you
get back once you put yourself out there
but you know just don't forget who you
are and just
enjoy it because for me i never in a
million years thought when i signed up
that i was gonna be sitting here as
american idol winner 2021. i bet i was
surprised when i got a golden ticket man
you know what i mean so
to be sitting here right now i'm talking
to you it's incred it's crazy so if
you're thinking about doing it sign up
and do it
because it changed my life it really did
perfect perfectly said i'll let you get
out of here
what do you want to say to your family
should they see this video
should they see you talking to
entertainment tonight as
the 2021 american idol what do you want
to let your family know
love you guys thanks for thanks for
believing in me whenever i gave up on
myself
you guys were you guys were the ones you
know so if it wasn't for them i wouldn't
be here
if it wasn't for other people believing
in me i wouldn't be here you know if it
wasn't for my mama
and my stepdad my dad and katy perry and
luke and lionel
all them believed in me whenever i
thought that i was done and
now this happened so you know believe in
yourself
i guess a little bit more if you're
going to do this show
believe in yourself but yeah just want
to say thanks to
everybody honestly i don't even know i
can't find words to say right now